[Music]
hello I'm Tim swathed I'm an engineer on
the Google developer relations team I
write code samples and tutorials mostly
focusing on Google's Big Data products
so speaking of data let's take a look at
some it's a bunch of numbers can you see
any patterns here probably not because
this is only 10% of the data so let me
bring it all on one slide now now it
should be really clear what's going on
well it's not clear to me that's because
I'm in human I can't ingest raw numbers
I need a human friendly visualization to
figure out what's going on and make
inferences about my data the data is
that we're gonna see in this demo is
mostly gonna be from bigquery big
queries a petabyte scale server list
data warehouse it gives you standard
sequel access to very large scale data
now if you store your data in something
like cloud sequel you can still get the
same power of the bigquery sequel engine
using big queries federated query
feature and now we've also launched the
BigTable federated query feature so if
you've got a bunch of streaming IOT data
into cloud BigTable you can access that
through the same sequel interface from
bigquery and we're also going to see a
little bit of connecting visualization
tools to cloud sequel as well I figure
you don't want to just look at random
data so let's look at some real world
stuff today we're gonna use Google's
public data set program and just a
handful of datasets from that some
weather data some data from various US
cities and the USA names database but
there are many more data sets available
and Google's adding more all the time
and for the tools that we're going to
use we're gonna see a bit of cloud data
lab which is a Python environment for
building visualizations and doing some
machine learning tasks we're gonna build
some dashboards with data studio and no
visualization talk is complete without
talking about spreadsheets so we're
gonna use Google sheets a little bit
today and then tableau is going to come
on stage and demonstrate their powerful
visualization tool Google Cloud connects
to many other visualization tools via
our partner companies a few of them are
listed here and many open source tools
lets you connect easily to Google Cloud
you're gonna see a lot of code today I
don't want you to worry too much about
understanding it because I'm going to
zip through it pretty fast
I made a blog post here you can go to
that link bitly visualize with GCP and
I've got a links to all the demos I've
done with source code yeah okay so why
are we visualizing our data the big
reason to visualize your data is you've
got a problem you want to solve so one
problem that a lot of people have is how
to name a child now that's a very
personal decision but I'm a geek so I
want to try to use big data to help
solve this the first thing to do when
you're building a visualization is to
build a summary of the data it doesn't
make sense
to try to see gigabytes and gigabytes of
data all in one plot we want to build a
nice summary and visualize that so the
way we're going to do that is with
bigquery so for our name assignment task
we might want to try to get a feel for
what names are out there and how are
they distributed so this query selects
the first name first letter of all the
names in the USA names database and
counts how many names start with that
letter now let's cut to the demo this is
that same query but in the bigquery UI
I'm going to click this red button here
to run the query and that's going to
take a few seconds and once that
completes
we're gonna click this save to Google
sheets button in the right corner and
then we'll click to view that it's
opened a new tab and then once that
loads up we're going to see the results
of our query in a Google sheet now I
don't care too much about the exact
numbers what I really want is to get a
feel for the distribution so I'm going
to insert a new chart Google sheets
recommends based on the types of data it
sees different visualizations
in this case it's suggesting a bar chart
which is exactly what we want let's
insert that so now we can clearly see
that the letter J on the left is by far
the most popular starting letter for
names and then it trails off slowly
eventually getting down to the letter U
which is so infrequently used it doesn't
even show up as a bar on this bar chart
so maybe if you're going for a unique
name pick one that starts with a letter
you Ursula or Ulysses might be a good
option there
we've explored our data by building a
visualization and the great thing about
Google sheets is it's easy to share it
with your co-workers so they can see
both the results of the query and the
visualizations you've built
problem with potential problem with
picking a name that starts with the
letter U I know I experienced this in
elementary school so you're back in
elementary school and you're lining up
to go outside for recess the teacher is
gonna line you up alphabetically and
it's really uncomfortable being at the
end of the line and it's also equally
uncomfortable being at the beginning of
beginning of the line so I know growing
up I wanted to be in that nice
comfortable center spot so let's see if
we can build a visit
visualization to help optimize for that
in our name so to summarize the data
we're gonna run a different sequel query
in this case we're looking at all the
names in the data set and counting how
many people total have had that name and
that might seem like a lot of data and
it is but it's a small enough set that
our visualization tools can handle it
and it lets us filter it in different
ways after we've run our initial query
this is cloud data lab it's a Python
Jupiter notebook environment and what
that means is it's built of these gray
boxes which are called cells so these
cells have Python code in them and you
see they're highlighted in grey right
now that means I haven't run them yet so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna click
through and hit the shift and enter key
on my keyboard and that's going to run
the code live so the first thing we're
doing is importing some libraries those
libraries might be familiar to many
Python programmers we're just using
matplotlib which is very common for
building visualizations in Python and
pandas for doing our analysis and also
doing our bigquery query so our query
completed and you see there's about
30,000 rows here so let's build a chart
of that this is called a Pareto chart
it's basically a bar chart because you
can see the bars here very much like the
previous plot we saw but then there's
this extra line graph here and what that
line graph represents is the cumulative
total so for example at the letter I you
see it crosses the forty percent mark
that means 40 percent of names begin
with the letters a through I so anything
at I or appearing before it now what
we're looking for is that nice center
spot so we're looking for where across
is the 50 percent mark which seems to be
at about the letter J so let's zoom in
on that so here's another Pareto plot
this time with the first two letters of
the different names this time starting
with the letter J and we're looking for
that 50% mark again so we've got the
letters Jo so maybe start a name that
begins with Jo so zoom in again and
again look for that 50% mark line and we
see a crosses at Jo are now for our
final visualization we're actually going
to do a table and a table is technically
a visualization but in this case it is
the most appropriate one because we're
looking for us
specific name so we're looking for that
exact 50 percent mark right where our
crosses and you see there's some pretty
close ties but Jordan is our perfectly
unbiased name if you pick the name
Jordan you're going to have the best
chance of being at the center of those
lines in the elementary school all right
so that was a bit silly so let's get
back to some serious data this actually
does mean something this represents the
last 10 years of weather data from
Austin Texas so Austin's famous for many
things and many festivals but one of
those is the hace Austin City Limits
Music Festival
so this festival has been going on for
over 10 years and a few years ago back
in 2009 they switched from being on a
weekend primarily in September to a
weekend in October now my Austin friends
have many theories about this but the
most common one seems to be it's really
hot in Austin in September especially
for an outdoor music festival where
you're out in the Sun all day
so my friends hypothesis is that the
organizers switched to October to beat
the heat now that's a great theory and
it it seems to make some intuitive sense
but let's use some big data and see if
this hypothesis is correct the first
thing we're going to do is build a
summary so we're going to run another
bigquery query this query selects data
from the NOAA weather public data set so
that data set is over a hundred years of
temperature data from weather stations
across the world so the way we're going
to filter it down is just select the
Austin Texas weather station and limit
to just the past 10 years of weather
data
again we're gonna use data lab notebook
and the same libraries pandas and
matplotlib
and this query might take a little bit
longer because it's a slightly larger
data set but it's still pretty fast now
let's plot this data out so now this is
the exact same set of data that you saw
in that slide but it should be a lot
clearer the patterns here so I've taken
ten years of data and then I've overlaid
them on top of each other so that you
can see the seasonal changes so the
x-axis here is the day of the year and
the y-axis is the temperature in
Fahrenheit and red means the high
temperature for the day blues the low
temperature and gray is the average
temperature for the day so one thing you
can definitely see here is it's a lot
hotter in summer as we'd expect and
actually the variance between
temperatures is a lot lower in the
summer months versus the winter months
they really change throughout the the
days in the winter but this graph
doesn't answer our question what we want
to know is where our music's festivals
lie on this line so let's see that I've
zoomed in a little bit on the left is
one of the music festival weekends that
happened in September and on the right
the blue line is one of the music
festivals that happened in October so we
can definitely see a downward trend here
there's about five degrees difference
between October and September and the
high temperatures and low temperatures
but five degrees is not a big difference
so maybe that's not the primary reason
the organizers picked October as the
month
one thing about choosing October is the
first year that the Austin City Limits
Music Festival was in October there were
torrential downpours all weekend so this
outdoor music festival was a really
muddy mess and they had spread compost
out on the lawn before and so it smelled
really bad too
so maybe if you're picking an ideal
weekend based on the weather for your
outdoor music festival maybe pick it on
more than just the temperature data
so speaking of austin i used to live
there for about five years or so and one
of the problems I encountered and wish I
had a visualization now solve was
choosing where to live I'm a big public
transit nerd I like to take the bus and
the light rail whenever I can even in
Austin where it's a hundred degrees out
and I'm outside in the hot Sun I'll
still take the bus
so maybe my ideal spot would be close to
a reliable public transit station the
other thing about living in Austin is
you learn to love the taco you end up
eating tacos every meal of the day but
especially breakfast so my ideal spot
would be somewhere that's both close to
a reliable transit but also close to
some of my favorite taco shops so it's
uh let's build a vistas visualization to
help us solve this problem we're gonna
summarize the data again again with
bigquery this time we're gonna query a
dataset called cap metrics which was
uploaded by a member of the open data
community Shawn cascade at a public
bigquery data set and this data includes
bus tracking data so times and locations
of all the buses as well as the bus
stops so what I'm selecting here is
whenever our bus is at a bus stop I want
to know is that bus on schedule or off
schedule because I'm using that as my
measure of how reliable the buses are
I'd rather the bus be on schedule than
off schedule
to the demo this is another notebook and
this is more Python code here I'm using
pandas and matplotlib but a few other
libraries here to work with geographic
data and also I uploaded the query
results to a cloud sequel Postgres
instance the reason I did that is
because the Postgres instance supports
the post GIS extension which allows me
to do
GIS queries against it in this case I've
got my bus tracking data and I also
added a table table for my favorite taco
shops so I'm selecting the distance to
the closest taco shop via sequel all
right so the query is finished let's
build a plot of this this is called a
Veroni diagram it gives you an idea of
where the bus stops are that's these
blue dots here but also the area served
by that bus stop these blue dots are
surrounded each by a polygon that
polygons eat any point within that area
the nearest bus stop is the blue circle
contained within it
now I've plotted this latitude longitude
data on a just a regular XY plane and
that's not quite the right thing to do
so let's plot it out on a map instead so
I'm going to convert this Veroni diagram
into a Geo JSON and then I'm gonna plot
it out using a library called leaflet so
here's all our bus stop areas plot it
out on a map so you can see the
different areas served by the bus stops
overlaid on the map of Austin this
doesn't quite answer our question so let
me color it in
based on the reliability of the buses in
those stations so now we can see the
dark purple areas are where the buses
are not so reliable they're off schedule
on average by quite a bit in the later
areas are where the public transit is
pretty reliable
and they're on schedule and most of the
time so that's great we could use this
to find an apartment but it doesn't
solve my taco problem so let's uh let's
combine the taco table with this data
set so now I've overlaid where all my
favorite taco shops are and then I've
colored it in not only by the public
transit reliability but also the
proximity to a taco shop so the light
areas are the areas that have reliable
transit and are close to a taco shop and
the darker areas are either not reliable
or far away from a taco shop or both so
looking at panning around here we can
see a few possible choices if we want to
live on the south side I happen to know
this is William cannon road down here
and it's by Torchy's tacos if we want to
live on the east side there's not too
many choices but we've got a little spot
of white here by the Plaza SLT a light
rail station and L cholito
or if we want to live on the north side
there's a nice spot up here across
Torchy's tacos and on Burnett Road
alright so we found the perfect place to
live it's got reliable public transit
and proximity to delicious tacos
so let's imagine for a Bennett that
you're a data scientist and you're
working for the public transit company
so you just saw my talk and you want to
cut down on the number of those purple
areas so it's your job to help keep
these buses running on time so you're
gonna do the same kinds of analysis that
we just saw but eventually you're gonna
want to share your work with one of your
co-workers so one way to do that is to
take a screenshot of your visualization
and then send it off in an email to your
coworker now that works fine they're
gonna see the exact same image you saw
but there's a problem with that
buses move around so by the time your
coworker gets to that email an hour
later the problem will have evolved so
ideally we'd have a live dashboard that
shows not the data an hour ago but the
data as it is right now and we're going
to use data studio to build a dashboard
like that
data studio allows you to connect to
bigquery as we've seen in the other
visualizations in this talk but it also
supports Google Analytics and many other
data sources in this case we're going to
use a bigquery query so this query is
very similar to the previous one we saw
I'm still looking at how far off
schedule the buses are on average but
this time I'm splitting up by the day of
the week in the hour of the day because
I want to see how the problem changes
over time cutting to the demo I built
this data studio dashboard so I used
data Studios filtering mechanism to
build seven different graphs here each
showing a different day of the week and
then I've got a line graph for each one
the x-axis is the time of the day and
the y-axis is how far off schedule are
the buses on average for that hour so
you can see the buses start off on time
which makes sense they've just started
their route and then it get more and
more off schedule throughout the day and
the afternoon they catch up a little bit
but then rush hour hits and they get way
out
so the great thing about data studio is
this share button up here you can click
that it gives you a link you can send
that off to your coworker and then when
they load this page up it's going to
rerun that query and they'll see a live
view of the data and if you want their
help building this dashboard maybe you
want them to add some new visualizations
to it you can give them edit access just
like you would a Google Doc now I've
only used line graphs in this dashboard
but data studio also supports bar charts
Geographic maps scatter charts all the
visualizations we saw today and more
data studio is great for this sharing
use case it's not the tool I'd use for
the analysis part the exploration phase
figuring out what transformations I want
to make to the data and how I want to
visualize it for that I like to use
those notebooks it's really handy to be
able to run some Python code to grab
some data filter it in a bunch of ways
and try out different visualizations so
speaking of code again here's the link
to the blog post in case you forgot it
and you want to look up the code I used
to build these demos but if you're not a
coder there's another option
and that's tableau tableau is a powerful
visualization and analysis tool no
coding skills required and to show you
more about that let me introduce VY T
Krishnan who's going to come to stage
and show you how GC p customers are
using tableau to gain insights about
their big data thank you so my name is
VI e lead partnerships for tableau so my
job at tableau is to work with Google
and all the other technology partners we
collaborate with and that help our
customers be more successful with
tableau and today I'm gonna talk to you
about first of all how a tableau
integrates with the Google platform why
customers choose Google why customers
choose tableau and why the joint value
that we provide is a win for both of us
and our customers then I'm gonna get
into some best practices for using
bigquery and tableau together but before
that I just want to you know do quick
show of hands how many are familiar with
what tableau is or are already using
tableau so that's great right so it
seems like everyone has had a chance to
you know experience tableau or already
using it but I'm sure many of you have
sometimes struggled with performance and
and haven't quite understood how to work
with that and and we're gonna talk about
some best practices and
before I will end I'll just get into a
quick demo where we'll connect to a
billion rows worth of New York City Taxi
data and I'll talk about some big
customer wins we've had including you
know several that were featured on the
keynote stage yesterday so here's what
the Google tableau data platform looks
like so tabla is just a top layer of a
very deep stack that most customers use
to organize and analyze information
inside their enterprises right so the
way this works in most cases you have
some raw data this could be you know
coming from sensors this could be sales
this could be marketing data it goes
into Google Cloud storage then it flows
into one of many different databases all
of which tableau offers direct native
connectivity to so we're talking cloud
sequel you know all the marketing
website data goes into Google Analytics
Google sheets Google bigquery we you'll
soon offer the right connectivity to
Google BigTable and the cloud data proc
which is Google's Hadoop as a service
platform now many of you might ask well
what is native connectivity right so it
native connectivity essentially tableau
and Google working together to make sure
our connection is tuned for performance
and makes full use of the tableau
feature set right when we just connect
via ODBC it it's not always optimized so
we have put our both our engineers a bit
hard at work to make sure this
integration is performant and works
great for our customers
so we're talking about Google bigquery
today I want to spend a couple of
moments just to you know emphasize why
our customers like Google bigquery and
you know I'm not gonna dwell on this
because I'm sure many of you have
attended several other sessions that
cover this but what I like the most
about the slide is the gbq is doing away
with all the traditional issues you face
with data warehouses on the left-hand
side right you don't have to design
build and manage servers you don't have
to forecast capacity
it'sit'sit's and when you do that
there's typically a lot of you know
total cost associated with it which
creates a barrier to entry with Google
bigquery you have a serverless
architecture so it's completely
abstracted out from the customer you can
automatically scale storage up and down
based as your needs and and your usage
grow and you know in in totality what
this means is the customers customer
gets agility right they don't have to
necessarily invest upfront and you know
deal with the risk of you know just just
letting their or they don't have to deal
with a lot of risks right so as with any
cloud platform you you have out there
Google bigquery makes sure that they
don't have to invest a ton in capex and
most is effects and scalable and agile
so let's talk about some of the common
problems you face with analyzing data
well first is as with many legacy bi
products and in fact a surprising number
of new vendors especially in the data
discovery space they make you write code
to connect the data right which is great
for a DBA or someone who's a developer
but if your business user or someone who
is close to the actions that come out of
his work and
knows the data you don't have to spend
time doing that now once you're able to
connect the data it's typically very
hard to create a vis right you you need
to know what question you're going to
ask before you analyze it but that's not
how data exploration works 90% of the
time I just have a billion rows and I
don't even know what question to ask I
need to just explore away and let that
data guide what that question should be
right so you know imagine a platform
that's asking you to you know click on a
bunch of wizards or choose a chart type
even before you've asked that question
right that's that's we we wanted to
disrupt that experience right and and
I'll talk about how tableau solves that
and finally once you've created
something you have to share and you know
Tim alluded to this a little earlier
share that work with the rest of your
organization you know this could be
internally with stakeholders or clients
to make sure that that analysis is acted
on right and again that's that is
typically not been easy in in
traditional VI platforms so how can tab
lo help well first of all you can
connect to all the Google data sources I
talked about and a whole slew of other
data sources in a minute right and now I
firmly believe that it across most
organizations not all your data rests in
one place right so you may have a ton of
data in gbq but you have data and
salesforce if dayton Marketo you still
have some of those old spreadsheets that
you know some of some of your teams may
be continuing to update on an ongoing
basis that you want to bring into your
analysis right we allow you to bring all
those data sources together and we are
not just a visualization tool so I I
know like when we started out and back
in 2003 the first couple of years the
market sauce of a shiny new toy but over
the years you know we've expanded our
capabilities we're now proud to be an
enterprise ready mission-critical
platform the
allows people not just to analyze and
export data but to share govern and and
collaborate and distribute it in a way
that makes people feel empowered so and
an IT can also participate now in you
know driving the analytics direction of
organizations right so your business
users are governed without feeling that
they're being governed and IT is now
able to focus all this time on
high-level security and data management
tasks
so how do tableau and Google or work
together again it comes down to three
things speed and agility we deploy on
the Google cloud engine you can connect
the minutes start analyzing data right
away GCP offers scale and agility
there's no guessing capacity issues you
don't have to forecast in advance scale
up and down as you need and tableau
works with all kinds of data and
unlimited amounts and you illustrate
that in the demonstration a little bit
and of course there's you know TCO which
both of us are really great at ours has
been ranked the lowest among all the
major BI vendors and GCP can be up to
40% cheaper than cloud competitors so
what are some best practices for tableau
and bigquery together again I'm not
going to dwell on all of these but
there's a few ones that I would like to
just double click on the first and so
the top half is all the you know best
practices that have to deal with Google
bigquery so first of all win a
visualization is not performing 50% of
the time where I would say 70 75 percent
of time you have in to and your data
source well is a data source that
performs against the data source right I
always like to tell my customers right
if you're sequel against the data source
is taking 50 seconds tableau cannot make
that 40 seconds right so I always have
to start with the data source first so
what do you do
avoid select star why is that because
Google is a Google bigquery is a
columnar store so what that means is
every column is a is in a different
physical block so you know if you choose
your columns and not do select stars
queries are going to be more performant
denormalization is your best friend
so you know Google bigquery is beta
joins but if you're able to pre join and
flatten out your structures and you know
essentially you know trade your storage
for compute resources well obviously
gonna be paying more for stories for
paying a lot less for compute and I
think that's a very effective trade-off
your queries are gonna come back faster
so always denormalize your tables and
actually this works for tableau as well
we like the normalized structures
because it helps us fire that analytical
query a lot better leverage natural
partitioning or use explicit charting so
again the point we're trying to make is
avoid full table scans so and leverage
natural partitioning which is usually
your record createdate so if you have a
bunch of tables and you have one table
for each date you can use that or you
know make sure you're using some sort of
filter to not scan everything and just
scan what you need on the tableau side
you know again I have seen billions of
rows worth of data a you know experience
or or people experience 20x performance
improvements over several billions of
rows of rate data just because they had
a solid indexing and partitioning
strategy avoid too many filters avoid
large data set to second data set
blending you know the the the thing
about tableau is just because it's easy
it allows people to do a lot of things
and just because you can do it doesn't
mean you should so avoid that and you
know stay away from having large number
of schemas and columns you know it's
always good to know in advance or try to
figure out what are the columns you want
to explore versus what's junk and also
only you know connect to what you know
for sure you're gonna use so with that
let's get into a really quick demo so
here I am connected to tableau desktop
so this is what an analyst would use to
create visualizations right so this is
the analyst and I am going to go ahead
and connect to Google bigquery instance
you
and want to highlight some of the
improvements we've made recently you
know in in support of the some features
features the Google bigquery team of
develop the first thing is since gbq
charges for storage and compute
separately you can now use the building
project feature the point or to charge a
certain project right so imagine you
have a bunch of stakeholders or clients
you can actually charge all the queries
to that one project which is which saves
a lot of headache down the road the
second thing is we have now the ability
to write custom sequel which can be
validated right away why would you want
to write custom sequel a bunch of
different reasons
you know sometimes for instance you
might want to use a native Google
bigquery function let's say you want to
use the wild-card function how many of
you are aware of that where you can
actually do select star from table that
star so if you want to do something like
that
you can leverage custom sequel also we
have added a little flag that lets you
control whether you want to send a
legacy sequel or standard sequel so gbq
has now you know announced support for a
standard sequel which is anti sequel
compliant but you know there are several
customers who have views that have all
been written in legacy sequel right so
when that's a case you obviously want to
send legacy sequel and we give you that
option alright so let's go ahead and do
some analysis so here I am going to pull
I think it's about six or seven years
worth of New York City Taxi data all
downloaded from the NYC gov website and
staged into Google bigquery and I'm
gonna start asking some questions the
first thing I want to know is well how
many rows there are and let's do that I
think looks like there's about a
a little in excess of a billion rows and
you know this is a perfect example of an
analysis I'm going to do where I don't
even know what to ask well I'm just
gonna explore away right so first thing
I wanna know is well how have these
number of records trended over time so
how about I look at this by the pickup
date time and I'm gonna look at this by
year well that's kind of nice
what if I want to look at it by quarter
or month maybe it won't express this a
little differently that's a bar the
other question I might want to ask is
well how have the volumes of rides
changed over time by payment type so
that's that's one dimension that I see
in the data I have so I can bring that
into color and it's gonna fire that
query again
and hopefully it comes back in a bit now
while that happens let me also say tell
you the tableau is takes a hybrid
approach towards data so we allow our
customers to connect live but customers
are always you know encouraged to use
our tableau data extract if they only
want a snapshot in time so they can
always bring data into memory and we
have a lot of customers who may want you
know have trillions of records but to
prove a concept they just need data for
the last couple of years right so and
and you can you can use a tablet data
extract to do that so that's that's nice
and and what this is doing is it's it's
highlighting a problem that we see with
a lot of data which is dirty data right
so here I have cash transactions being
represented as multiple categories
someone want to just go ahead and Club
them as one so I'm gonna do that right
here and when I do that it doesn't
change the source all it's doing is it's
changing the metadata so now we will
have a new payment group created when
that happens I'm gonna go ahead and the
club all the are the credit card
transaction as one as well so let's do
that
the grouping that all into one
you
all right so and I'm gonna keep the
disputer transactions - so in fact I
think I think it might be useful to Club
that too because that is something
that's that I might want to analyze
further
all right so not surprisingly if you
look at the data from 2009 through 15
the proportion of credit card
transactions is increasing and and it's
not all that surprising but you know if
you wanted to make the case a lot better
you can also add a little table
calculation and express this result as a
percentage of total
right so that just makes it you know
clearer a lot nicer what I can also do
now is ask a couple of different
questions maybe I want to look at just
the disputer transactions maybe I want
to know when do all these disputed
transactions happen and where do these
happen and does that tell me something
about where these you know or where as a
cabbie what are some areas that I might
want to avoid so I'm just gonna go ahead
and say keep only and I'm gonna clear
this table calculation
you
all right
and I'm gonna go ahead and duplicate
this sheet and now I'm gonna extra to
express this data live little
differently maybe I want a look at the
same information by our
and again nothing surprising not a ton
of rides happening in the wee hours of
the morning right but volumes grow as
you get later in the day the next
question is well can I hone in on
certain neighborhoods or certain
boroughs with in New York where all
these disputes happening the wee hours
of the morning so for that I am going to
represent this data geographically so
let's look at my latitudes and launch
two data
hey there you go that's what I wanted so
there's my latitude
and let's bring in my longitudes here
and tabla is automatically by the way
geocoded this information so it
recognizes well described addresses it
recognizes boroughs in New York
it recognizes zip codes but you know if
you don't have that you can use a whole
range of geocoding resources to bring
latitudes and longitudes and actually
have have them inside tableau
now you see that there's some junk in
here which I mean some of those rides
have been coated as happening in Africa
and Antarctica and obviously I don't
want that so I'm just gonna go ahead and
hone in i'm just those rights that are
coded correctly and that's a lot of
right so why don't we focus in and just
clean up clean this up a little bit and
i can change the map layer as well
nicer and I can change the opacity just
so it's nicer to look at and now I can
bring this all into a dashboard and
actually connect these different views
I can go ahead and make
it's laid out right
enable action filters
and with that I can use one view to
filter the other all right so obviously
we see here there's a lot of activity
around LaGuardia JFK you know some busy
thoroughfares around Brooklyn and
Williams in Williamsburg and Midtown is
always crazy even in the wee hours this
morning so again just a very quick
illustration of you know how all of this
comes together and again this is this
was done off a billion rows so how are
customers
leveraging tableau and bigquery together
so here's you know three different
examples we're you know a fairly
horizontal platform you know we have
customers across all verticals using
tableau we're in about 95 percent of the
fortune 500 companies but the three I
want to highlight are one which is Kabam
very small gaming company lots of data
they have you know they've had a
relationship at Google for years and
they're asking questions around their
gaming data right they want to know you
know user behavior where do people get
stuck right what are some you know how
do I design the game so people spend
more these are the kinds of questions
they're asking you have a University of
Colorado at Denver and they just came
out for the press release today they're
bringing in their EHR data combining
with patient data and environment data
to deliver personalized medicine and of
course I'm not gonna talk about Home
Depot you guys heard from them on the
keynote stage yesterday so with that you
know just before I end here are some
resources for you guys on you know how
the two platforms work together if you
have some product related questions
please feel free to reach out to me and
if you want to just try this just go
ahead and download a trial of tableau
and a trial of Google bigquery connect
the two there's a whole bunch of public
data sources out there that Tim
appointed you guys to all that New
York's data is available on the web
there's a Medicare data
and you know you can explore them to
your heart's content
also check out that the the white paper
I may or may not have talked about but
all the best practices that I covered
have been you know detailed in the white
paper and there's a lot of examples in
there as well for those of your existing
customers and have been using the two
platforms together for years so if you
want to see more about data studio
there's there was a talk yesterday about
that and the recordings are ready up
there's a couple talks about bigquery
you can check those out and there's a
great talk by Philippe about the public
data set program I recommend you go to
those and then if you want to try any of
these firsthand you can go to these code
labs this is the URL for the Google
quick labs there's a couple related ones
there you can try out bigquery with the
Wikipedia public data set and you can
try out data lab and some of the cloud
ml engine features that are tucked into
that that I didn't quite get to today
[Music]
you